notre objectif était de mener des
recherches empiriques impartiales sur les capacités humaines exceptionnelles
ESP précognition
psychokinésie il y avait
des cas vraiment exceptionnels tout document judith
était différent même si nous n'avions aucune idée à
quel point pouvez-vous nous dire votre nom
s'il vous plaît
mmm Judith Winstead vous savez quelle est votre
date de  Naissance Judith le 18 février 1935,
combien de frères et sœurs avez-vous,
allez-vous bien cher saignement Oh mon Dieu,
vous êtes-vous mordu,
elle a surpassé tous les sujets que nous aurions jamais
étudiés, essayez quatre sept fois trois et
quatre, attendre semblait des choses incroyables dans le
passé, mais rien de tel  quelque chose était
en elle pas une maladie
pas un parasite un mal la croyance était
que s'ils pouvaient contrôler son
corps physique, ils pourraient contrôler la façon dont la force se
manifestait posséder la possession qui
était l'intention du gouvernement depuis le
début de l'armer vous n'arrivez pas
à  jouer à des jeux avec le diable et si vous le
faites, vous êtes sûr de ne pas pouvoir établir
les règles, ce n'était pas comme les livres ou
les films c'est réel
tu ne comprends pas je vois ce qui se
passe tu pousses trop loin